[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> All right. Now we're on to the fun stuff. Can we start optimizing now?
>> Yep. Let's just focus on the steps before
the render tree construction, so, the DOM and CSSOM,
because those are usually the steps that are the
worst offenders and make your page. Render very slowly.
>> Well, we did talk about streaming HTML to the client as fast
as possible so the browser can start building the DOM. Is there anything else?
>> So that's definitely one. What about the size of the HTML?
>> Hm. Well, I'm going to go ahead and
guess we should keep it as small as possible.
>> Yep. That's another good one. Let's take
a look at some strategies that will help us
with this. Let's say we want to optimize the HTML file in front of us. The first
thing to notice is that we have CSS
comments, HTML comments, and JavaScript comments. Now, these comments
are very helpful for developers. But guess what
the browser's going to do when it encounters them.
>> It's going to ignore them.
>> Exactly. There's no point in even shipping them to the browser. We can
minify the file and reduce its size.
To learn more about minification check the link
in the instructor notes. Once you've done that you should also compress the file
and make sure they are cached by
the browser. Once again, check the instructor notes.